اذا موسكو وكيا شهدتا هجمات متبادله
بالطائرات المسيره وادت لبعض الخسائر
الماديه والبشريه صباح اليوم استهدف ما لا
يقل عن 30 مسيره العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
وضربت ثلاث مسيرات مبانيه سكنيه بينما
اعلنت السلطات اسقاط القسم الاكبر منها
بحسب وسائل الاعلام محليه في الروايه
الرسميه قالت وزاره الدفاع في بيان ان
اوكرانيا حاولت شن هجوم بطائرات دون طيار
على منشات في موسكو بمشاركه ثمان مسيرات
تم تدميرها جميعا هجوم اليوم ليس الاول
الذي يستهدف موسكو لكنه يعد الاقوى بعد
هجوم الكرملين في الثالث من الشهر الجاري
اصابع الاتهام الروسيه وكما هو متوقع
اشاره لاوكرانيا التي نفت الا ان مساعد
الرئيس الاوكراني توقع زياده مثل هذه
الهجمات ومع استمرار التحقيقات وعدم اعلان
الطرف المهاجم مسؤوليته بدا الحديث عن
الهجوم وان كان داخليا ام خارجيا احد
الاحتمالات ان تكون المسيرات قد انطلقت من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من اقرب نقطه على
الحدود الاوكرانيه الى موسكو ولكن المسافه
تزيد على 500 كيلومتر ليطرحه هنا سؤال عما
اذا كانت اوكرانيا تمتلك مسيرات ذات مدى
طويل قادره على التخفي وتجنب الرادارات
والدفاعات الجويه الروسيه طول مسيره
المسيره من اوكرانيا الى موسكو الفرضيه
الثانيه المطروحه هي احتمال ان تكون
الهجمات تمت بتنفيذ خلايا نائمه داخل
روسيا نفذت سابقا عمليات في الداخل الروسي
نتحدث هنا مثلا عن الهجوم الذي اودى بحياه
مراسل الحربي المقرب من الكريم وهو فلادين
تتارسكي الذي قتل بانفجار بانفجار تمثال
مفخ اهدي له بمقهى فيتش في الثاني من
ابريل الماضي الاتهام وجه لمجموعات مق من
المعارض المسجون الاكسينافالني وبالتعاون
مع الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه لاحقا اتهمت
مجموعات معارضه داخل روسيا ايضا بمحاوله
اغتيال السياسيه والكاتب زخار بليبيين في
انفجار عبوه ناسفه على طريق كان يسلكها
بسيارته في السادس من هذا الشهر عده
فرضيات تطرح اذا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات